uh what do you make of the other
the other big uh player china
uh they seem to have a very different
messed up but also
functioning system they seem to be much
better at encouraging entrepreneurs
they're choosing winners
but like what do you make of the entire
chinese system
uh like why does it work as well as it
does currently
what are your concerns about it and what
are
its threats to the united states or
uh possible you know it's a what is it
you said like
wisdom isn't when two ideas come
together is there some possible
benefits of these kinds of ideas coming
together
it's amazing what china has done but i
would say to put it in perspective if
you compare them
to japan south korea taiwan hong kong
and singapore
they've still done much worse not even
close
yes and that's both living standards or
i hesitate to cite democracy as an
unalloyed good in and of itself but
there's more freedom in all those other
places
by a lot so china has all these problems
of history
but they've managed as actually the
soviets did in the middle of the 20th
century
one of the two great mass migrations
from the countryside to cities
which boosts productivity enormously and
will sustain totalitarian systems
but they moved from a totalitarian
system to an oligarchy
where the ccp is actually
at least for a while he has been really
good at governing have made a lot of
very good decisions you have to admit
that
i don't know how long that streak will
continue with one person
so much now holding authority
in a more extreme manner the selection
pressures for the next generation of
high-level ccp members probably become
much worse
you have this general problem of the
state-owned enterprise as losing
relative productivity
compared to the private sector well
we're going to kind of
hold jack ma on this island and he can
only issue like weird hello statements
it kind of smells bad to me i don't feel
that it's about to crash
uh below but i don't see them
supplanting america
as like the world's number one country i
think they will muddle through
and have very serious problems but
there's enough talent there they will
muddle through
is there ideas from china from anywhere
in general of
large-scale role of government that you
find might be useful like
andrew yang recently ran on the platform
of ubi
right uh universal basic income is there
um
some interesting ideas of large-scale
government sort of welfare programs
at scale that you find interesting
well keep in mind the current version of
the chinese communist party post mao
dismantled what was called the iron rice
ball
so took apart the health care
protections a lot of the welfare system
a lot of the guaranteed jobs so the
economic rise of china coincided with
the weakening
of welfare i'm not saying that's causal
per se
but people think of china as having a
government that takes care of everyone
it's very far from the truth
and by a lot of metrics i don't mean
control over people's lives
i don't mean speech but by a lot of
metrics economically we have a lot more
government than they do
so what one means here by like
government private control
i don't think you can just add up the
numbers and get a simple answer
they've been fantastic at building
infrastructure in cities
in ways that will attract people from
the countryside
and furthermore they more or less
enforce a meritocracy in this sense
like if you're a kid of a rich guy
you'll get unfair privilege
that's unfair but systems can afford
that if you are smart and from the
countryside and your parents have
nothing
you will be elevated and sent to a very
good school graduate school because of
the exam system
and they do that and they mean that very
consistently
it's like the soviets had a version of
that like for jazz and romantic piano
not for everything but where they had it
like
yeah again they were tremendous right
yeah exactly so yeah
chinese have it in so many areas a
genuine meritocracy
in this one way that moves people from
the world to this
big city and that's that's all that's a
big boost of productivity for some
amount of time
and when they get there they're taken
seriously jack ma was riding a bicycle
teaching english in his late 20s
he was a poor guy so
not a society of credentialism or in
america is way too much
a credentialist society
you